the british capitals grappling with june
temperatures rarely seen in the united
kingdom
a questionable time perhaps for team
building exercises in the park
for others though it's a chance to do as
little as possible and for some an
opportunity to dust off membership to
the city's most exclusive pools
away from the stifling heat of the
capital this is brighton on the south
coast where thousands jostled for a
patch of beach
and a space to cool off
i'm from cyprus and now in cyprus it's
raining
and i'm in london and i'm boiling here
so
something
must change we need to take precautions
about the climate change
for a country that's made an art form of
complaining about the usually wet
weather this heat gives people here
something else to grumble about but
there's a seriousness about these
soaring temperatures real concern about
how climate change may start to affect
people's everyday lives
in the french capital sweltering heat's
been worsened by pollution making it
dangerous for the vulnerable to go out
and in the spanish capital madrid where
temperatures have exceeded 40 degrees
celsius for several weeks the
government's issued an extreme weather
warning due to the presence of sand and
dust from the sahara desert little
comfort for those struggling to work
outside
climate scientists are in no doubt about
why this is happening
we're warming our climate generally so
the average temperatures have risen by
just over one degree celsius since the
pre-industrial period and that means
that the hot extremes that we see every
summer are becoming at least one degree
hotter they're also becoming more
frequent and they're also lasting longer
and climate activists are threatening
more decisive action to perceived
inaction by governments and big business
similar to the extinction rebellion
protests that shut down parts of central
london a few years ago
we're fed up of of hearing the rhetoric
we need meaningful action and if our
leaders are incapable of doing that
they're not capable of getting off of
their fossil fuel addiction they're just
doubling down on it and continuing to
pursue
new fossil fuel investments continue to
subsidise this harmful industry
then we have to call them we have to
call them out and education is key to
the public and also understanding the
role of non-violent civil resistance in
this moment because everything else has
failed
climate scientists say the next decade
will be defined by greater extremes of
weather but the theory is it will also
be shaped by our collective failure to
do more
new barca al jazeera london